all right of course raider's happy to
have him some of the best stories are
the stories that we
really don't have a chance to do very
often remember those fun summer
vacations when you
did something unusual or kind of unique
take for example
fishing fly fishing we don't have a
chance very often so when we do get out
and fling a few flies it's pretty cool
it was sunday morning as we worked our
way toward a 50-yard stretch of the
river just below the jordanelle dam
outside heber city we were on the water
by 6 30.
it was a brisk morning as the cold
canyon air cut through our light summer
jackets
seemed like we were waiting for the sun
and the fish to rise with equal
anticipation
it wasn't long before the small
cutthroat trout started eying our small
flies and by 8 o'clock
our fishing battles were underway i
think it's the thrill of watching people
catch their first fish again or watching
the excitement on their faces that to me
is is
one of the most exciting things ever and
it kind of brings that joy
rekindles it back into my own life where
it's like hey this is fun
it's seeing something new it's pretty
cool
[Music]
look no way
fooling fish is a reward for any angler
who enjoys
the snapping line and bending pull it
was a rewarding challenge that never
gets old
it's really cool you really want to
bring it in fast and
hope it's big sometimes not big but it's
still fun we caught
several fish each and on a fly rod it's
more natural
it seems than bait fishing it seems so
it was a lot of fun the hour seemed to
pass like minutes
after catching and releasing about 15
trout our fly fishing adventure had come
to an end
like a snag on a low hanging branch it
was over but not without thoughts of
sitting a future
5 a.m wake-up call and returning to
heber valley where a river runs through
it
yeah it's i mean it's hit or miss
sometimes it's awesome sometimes it's
not but
the thing that keeps you out is is the
thrill of feeling that tug on the other
line
and uh and the beauty of that species of
fish whether it's a brown trout or
rainbow
it's it's awesome alright that was so
much fun still